[Applaudissements]
ça et gilles verdez une pourquoi vous
n'aimez pas jean messia pourquoi alors
non mais parce que vous avez des idées
bien sûr qu'ils sont très divergentes
oui mais est-ce que ce soit vous êtes
capable de vous de lui pardonner ce qui
s'est passé entre vous et de reprendre
le dialogue dans une future émission
justement je voudrais faire un geste
c'est quoi votre anniversaire jean
messia je vais vous féliciter parce que
vous avez créé un institut et l'institut
apollon c'est une beauté regarde moi
sans rien que de penser ainsi que
regarde moi c'est pareil apollon symbole
de la musique et bien vous vous êtes le
roi du pipeau
[Applaudissements]
et vous dire messia vous n'avez pas de
visage c'est le très mal ce que vous
faites rentes a travaillé longtemps sa
blague la buba
après je vais l'attendre dans le couloir
pour lui monde y est un sel fille vous
avez fait ça j'en messia après je classe
les chroniqueurs et je vais dîner avec
eux et certains n'ont pas le cul propre
ici
alors je vais faire vous pouvez ne
dénoncez
vous montrez nous donc le ventre et rami
tout est faux mais s'il ya tout est faux
j'en ai ras-le-bol de vous alors jean
régnier
sentirez bien compris le métier de g le
métier de gilles verdez c'est d'attiser
la haine est stigmatisée quand est ce
que vous faites ce soir à du tout mais
si je vous dis vous verrez ce que moi si
vous voulez le système idéologique que
vous incarnez jeu l'exècre je n'aime pas
d'accord mais je distingue moi j'ai la
grandeur d'âme que vous n'avez
manifestement pas de distinguer entre
les idées portées par quelqu'un la vie
politique que ce quelqu'un peut avoir et
l'être humain qu'il ya derrière la vie
vous savez les hommes ne se réduisent
pas des as des idées ne se réduisent pas
des engagements politiques là par
exemple à l'excès avec cyril hanouna on
n'a pas du tout les mêmes idées mais ça
n'empêche que derrière cyril hanouna il
ya un être humain derrière moi il ya un
être humain mais retourne toi là il est
là regardez la za est
effectivement avec les chroniqueurs ici
oui bien sûr je ne partage pas leurs
idées ça m'empêche pas de les apprécier
sur le plan humain mais n'est ce pas là
justement la grandeur d'une démocratie
deux poubelles
non pas parce que deux fois à tous de
pouvoir discuter que de pouvoir discuter
débattre croisé même le faire sur le
plan privé mais en même temps trouver la
personne qui porte des idées que
pourtant je n'aime pas mal à trouver
sympathique elle a trouvé trouvé humaine
parce que parce que vous faites ce que
vous avez une femme il est bien que moi
je suis libère aussi et c'est parler des
êtres humains envoyez moi je n'attaque
jamais la personne mais vous vous n'êtes
qu'hypocrisie cela vous défendez des
idées en coulisse vous est même loin de
ces idées là vous n'avez aucune
sincérité mais si regardez vos costumes
ridicules téléguidées
pas du tout je vous expliquez vous
n'avez pas regardé les bons fait
semblant a fait semblant d'avoir des
costumes bas de gamme que vous portez
pour avoir l'air populaire
non mais ça c'est pas bien mais que je
suis allé parce que tomber la sagesse
qui est bas de gamme c'est ce que vous
dites oui les gens mais si un fret sur
faust et c'est ça qui m'énerve alors
s'il vous plaît ou déplaît guillaume et
moi je réponds d'agir parce qu'il fait
pratiquer la délation aux prétendants du
siècle oui moi j'ai pas honte de le dire
j'ai déjà dîné avec jean messia et cette
émission verrai ce que vous avez dit né
de plusieurs restaurants bars ou dans un
kebab non mais plus du réveil manger ou
au pied de touches et moi je l'invité
chez moi dit nenê 6 ouais et alors je
vous dire ça qui est bien
dessert
[Applaudissements]
cette émission l'a prouvé une chose
c'est que quel que soit votre origine
votre milieu social vos opinions
politiques ont plus rigoureux des
couleurs au lieu de diviser les jambes à
la politique conclu
[Applaudissements]
gilles verdez en fait vous n'êtes que n
vous transpirez lie to me sens très mal
et vous avez les yeux révulsés la bave
aux lèvres vous et que vous exhaler vous
exhaler une forme de haine je comprends
pas ce que je vous ai fait pour faire ça
écoutez moi je pense qu'effectivement
les idées c'est une chose l'être humain
en est une est trop trop vous le vouliez
ou non mais l'être humain vous le mettez
tout l'été ce quand vous avez balancer
des conneries sur les chaînes infos à la
dire les immigrés il faut qu'ils
rentrent chez eux moi mais non moi
j'aime où ça me fait rentrer chez lui
vous intervenez à l'humain vous avez à
faire c'est de l'humain temps c'est que
vous n'avez pas fait attention
naviguerez qui sont très fort
humainement moi j'ai des immigrés qui
sont très bons et là ça vous dérange pas
dîner chez d'y
répondre c'est une bonne question mais
je vais lui répondre alors la tournée le
groupe à l'humain j'ai lu ma quand on
parle de lille 2-2 de dona n'doh de
l'immigration parle d'un processus moi
si vous voulez pour halle pour la faire
courte on dit qu'on accueille toute la
misère du monde par humanisme par
bienveillance mais moi ma bienveillance
et mon humanisme ne consiste pas à
accueillir des gens à callas dans le but
d'en les goûts de calais ou dans le
cloaque de la chapelle voyez ça c'est
pas ma conception on a les moyens
d'accueillir les gens décemment propre
roman pour leur offrir un avenir pour
leur offrir un travail pour leur offrir
un logement décent pour leur offrir des
conditions de vie décentes soit on n'a
pas ces moyens là dans ce cas là on les
accueille pas enfin si les invités on
leur tire dessus
si vous habitez si vous habitez une
chambre de bonne de 5 mètres carrés vous
mbd vous invitez patron de personnes
chez vous pour les faire tous les
paliers
mais c'est vrai ça va j'ai une garden
est ce que vous dites pardon à jean
ristat ou est-ce que vous lui dites nico
mookie on aura la réponse de jean-michel
juste après mais je lui dis jamais
pardon je le redis unique au monde jean
bessière
[Applaudissements]
wilson iconique
mais qu'est ce qu'on lui dit il me dit
pas pardon s'il vous plaît
voilà le représentant de la
bienveillance de la tolérance
progressiste
mondial hors du parisien qui donne des
leçons à la terre entière à eux de
tolérance et de bienveillance pour tout
le monde sauf pour lui voilà le vrai
visage du progressisme gouverne mais je
vais vous montrer le vrai visage cagoulé
visage puisque on me dit toujours que je
vais être que jacques higelin et que je
stigmatise je te pardonne
[Applaudissements]
le dit cook est éliminatoire
forcément voilà donc j'en ai gardé n'a
pas voulu se réconcilier et on va
redonner à genlis ya donc pour l'instant
vous êtes toujours embrouillé oui